how's it going everybody it's Warren and
Marvel Studios and Sony Pictures have
worked out their deal for spider-man to
remain in the MCU and spider-man 3 is
about to begin production we have a lot
of news about spider-man 3 today
including when the film is going to
start production where they're going to
film it which also tells us where part
of the movie is going to take place a
hint at who the main villain could be
and of course the connection to venom
and Morbius so we have a lot to break
down today I'm still doing my Xbox one
and ps4 giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be subscribed with
notifications turned on like the video
and comment down below about the video
spider-man 3 is set to hit theaters on
July 16th of 2021
that's about a year and a half away and
according to comic book calm they have
learned that spider-man 3 is set to
begin filming and production in July the
production is scheduled to go on until
November but some interesting locations
have been revealed about where they're
going to be filming the film locations
are Atlanta New York Los Angeles and
Iceland
now Atlanta is sometimes used to
replicate New York in many film studios
do this in fact Marvel Studios did this
for Avengers endgame but they are also
filming in New York so if Atlanta is
going to double as New York and they're
also filming in New York it seems like
spider-man is actually going to be
returning home Peter Parker really
wasn't in New York that much in
spider-man far from home of course it
was about him being away from home but
many people wanted the nostalgic feel of
spider-man swinging on skyscrapers and
through the skyscrapers in the film
something that we briefly got at the end
where he swung with MJ well it looks
like spider-man is going to be returning
to New York so it looks like we are
going to get more of that and then you
have LA which of course all of the
studios are in LA so it makes perfect
sense that they would shoot there but
let's talk about Iceland many studios
have used Iceland as a production
location before including Marvel Studios
for Thor the dark world but why would
Marvel Studios be filming in Iceland
what do they need Iceland for well
Iceland has a vast scenery it's a
beautiful place with many locations that
look very different so Marvel Studios
for spider-man 3 is most likely using
Iceland to look like Russia and the
reason that they are most likely going
to do this is because they are planning
on introducing Kraven the hunter as the
villain of spider-man 3 Kraven the
hunter has been rumored to be the main
villain of spider-man 3 for some time
now and it makes perfect sense at the
end of spider-man far from home Mysterio
made everybody think that Peter Parker
was the villain he made everybody think
that he tried to kill multiple people
and he made everyone think that he
killed Mysterio and as we saw in the
Morbius trailer which I'll get into in a
bit everybody thinks that spider-man is
in fact a murderer
so we know that he's going to be on the
run in spider-man 3 and it seems like
it's going to be Kraven the hunter one
of spider-man's most formidable foes
that is going to be hunting him down now
chameleon was in spider-man far from
home and chameleon is the half-brother
of Kraven the hunter so perhaps it's his
brother chameleon who calls Kraven the
hunter to come hunt spider-man several
insiders in the community have been
teasing Kraven the hunter as the main
villain especially recently and it makes
a ton of sense if you consider what Sony
and Marvel are trying to do with
spider-man that creating their own
shared universe and they're setting up
the sinister six it's already been
confirmed that Sony is talking to Tom
Holland about a spider-man cameo in
venom 2 we also just got the Morbius
trailer which takes place in the same
universe that venom takes place in and
in the Morbius trailer we saw
spider-man's picture with the word
murderer over it but then we saw vulture
and everybody freaked out because
vulture is from the MCU so does this
mean that Morbius and venom take place
in the MCU well the answer is yes but
also know it's been reported that in the
new negotiations between Sony and Marvel
over spider-man remaining in the MCU
Sony worked out a deal for them to be
able to reference MCU characters and MCU
events in their own spider-man universe
so the events that happened in
spider-man far from home happened in the
same universe as Morbius and venom
however as the reports currently stand
the events that happen in Morbius and
venom aren't going to affect the MCU
only the spider-man film in the MCU this
is why they kind of are but kind of
aren't in the MCU it seems very clear
that Marvel and Sony are setting up the
sinister six
we have Kraven the hunter coming in his
brother chameleon vulture has made an
appearance in the Morbius trailer then
of course we have Morbius who knows if
Mysterio is actually dead or not and
then of course there's room for and
I was born to come in over a venom or
carnage depending on how venom 2 plays
out
we know that the deal worked out between
Sony and Marvel was for one spider-man
solo film and then a crossover film and
right now it's looking like the
crossover film is probably going to be
the sinister six right now that's what
several of the insiders in the community
are saying but nothing is confirmed yet
however with the production of
spider-man 3 happening very soon we're
going to find out a lot more including
who the main villain is going to be
which is most likely Kraven the hunter
so would you like this would you like
for Kraven the hunter to be the main
villain of spider-man 3 hunting him down
as he's running from the law and
eventually go on to set up the sinister
six for the next spider-man film and how
do you feel about the Sony verse kind of
going into the MCU
let me know all your thoughts in the
comments down below and let me know who
you think should play Kraven the hunter
also don't forget to leave a like on the
video and subscribe when notifications
turned on so you can stay up to date on
everything relating to spider-man and so
you can enter my giveaway for a chance
to win an Xbox one or ps4 I'm picking a
winner at five hundred and fifty
thousand subscribers as always thank you
all so much for watching we'll forth